[Music]
welcome to our session scalable and
manageable a deep dive into gke
networking best practices because we all
know how perhaps unnecessarily
complicated networking can be we kept
the title of the session long and dry
instead of making a brief and simple hi
my name is Bowie I'm an engineer on gke
networking hi my name is Mahesh Narayan
and I'm a product manager in GK as well
so the format of this session is going
to be a bit different you know bogie and
I get on a lot of calls with customers
talking about the issues you know design
and architectural considerations product
overviews so on and so forth so what we
are done is we are taken we have
encapsulated the customer questions and
we're going to try to come up with the
solutions and recommendations and best
practices that addresses those questions
the idea or the aim of this session is
to look into look under the hood at the
engine of GK and look at the different
advanced cluster management options and
fine-tune this engine some housekeeping
if you have any questions about the
sessions please session please go to
Dory Q&A it's an internal tool that we
have used quite a lot in Google and it
gives an opportunity for everybody to
ask questions if you like a question
please upload it so that it has a higher
probability of it being asked okay so
you start off dabbling with gke
our you know powerful orchestration and
cluster management service you know as
you spend more time you know your you
know your confidence grows your skill
set grows you know you you you start
building more and more application
mission-critical applications and
migrating them to G K G K star clusters
start seeing more and more traffic soon
enough your cluster size gradually
starts growing to a point where you
start running into scalable you know
scalability and manageability issues
these issues can often be avoided by
following best practices and guidelines
from day one so that's the crux of this
session we often hear from our customers
that you know they run into routes cota
as you know somebody
proving quota requires we see a lot of
you know quota increase increase in
quota requirement because of g'kar out
space clusters laying out your vp c is
the most important facet of deploying GK
clusters you know the one of the key
binary decisions that needs to be made
is whether you're going to use routes
based bluster or VPC native clusters now
what are these
you know kubernetes mandates spot the
pod connectivity and when a part is
talking to another part in a node it
uses the the cluster in the the bridge
interface to to make that happen but
across nodes you need some support from
networking to make that happen
both overlay and underlay so GK started
off with route space cluster and what it
did was it use static routes so it uses
static route the nodes used a static
route and announced itself as a next
stop to all the parts that it hosts it's
fine for a small cluster but as your
plus size grows you know your routes
quota also increased require your
requirements also increase so in
anticipation of growing clusters what it
did did was we came up with V PC native
clusters which under the hood uses alias
IP which basically is using secondary IP
on a siniface or on a NIC now V PC node
native mode is enabled by default and
the biggest advantage over route space
cluster is that it doesn't require that
many routes quota apart from scaling as
the name suggests it also natively
increased integrates with V PC fabric
allowing other functionalities and
features like shared V PC private
clusters flexible IP management art
snooping snooping you know snooping
checks so on and so forth so let's talk
about let's talk about IP management
most often the deployments are blocked
not because of some fancy new feature
but because of lack of contiguous IPS
you know I've been on many calls with
customers where they have a spreadsheet
with IP inventory and they're trying to
match the size of the scale of their
cluster with IPS so let's look at IP
management from GK what are some of the
resources that use this IPS and what
some of the options to reduce IP
utilization on GK so kubernetes itself
uses IPS liberally write the different
resources so before we get into I P
optimization let's look at what are the
different resources that uses IP there
are three rows resources that require
ip's your pods your nodes and your
services and at week via V so the nodes
use the primary range of a subnet the
pods use a secondary range of a subnet
and the service also uses a secondary
range of a subnet the service and the
pod secondary range need to be different
we don't allow you to use the same
secondary range now why we used Y we
what are the advantages of having
separate ranges for all these resources
there are few advantages the first is
you know it's more intuitive if you
heart if you have any net security
policies and from attacking tracking
perspective it's much easier to have
separate ranges you can grow each
resource independently and lastly you
know if you want to apply any security
pulse policy based on ciders it's also
easier so V PC native provides two modes
of IP allocation two resources one is
the auto IP mode where we take ever care
of everything
GK is responsibility to allocate IPS to
the different resources and it takes
care of ensuring there is no IP overlap
the drawback is that we assume certain
cluster size we assume a modder moderate
cluster size and end up taking an IP
block based on that assumption however
if you are building a small smaller
cluster you know you want final grain
control you can use a custom IP option
where you can decide the subnet you can
decide the range and reduce your overall
IP utilization one other way of reducing
your IP utilization is using the primary
range and the secondary range for pods
across different clusters right we don't
allow the secondary rates for services
to be shared across different clusters
but for pod for the pod primary and for
the node
for the pod secondary and for the node
primary you can use it across share it
across different clusters and last but
not the least there is a new knob that
we added called max pods per node so
let's talk about that
this is features just went into beta so
to understand the crux of this feature
let's define pod density as the number
of pods running per node so we talked
about how you need you define a pod
cluster or a pod range which allocates
pods to all the which allocates IPs to
all the pods in your cluster but since
the node is actually running those pods
the nodes need to carve carve out a
space a specific or a smaller cider from
this overall cluster right so with poor
density based config we have kind of
opened up this option to the customer
you decide how many pods you are going
to run per node and thereby the node
carves out that many IPs from the bigger
block so as an example let's say you
give a slash 20 for all your pods in a
cluster and you're trying to run eight
pods per node we take a slash 28 from
that overall slash 20 you know so the
obvious last 20 exhaust more slowly you
might ask why are we taking a slash 28
if it is only eight clusters in our
slice 29 that's because we take the
double the amount of IPS for avoiding
issues like IP reallocation when the
node you know goes up and down so this
is an example of you know how how you
can create a smaller cluster nodes per
cluster 12 so you take a slash 28 for
that services you applying to run 20
services on this cluster so you take a
slash when you sign for that and the
cluster pod range that you define is a
slash 24 now you define like as we
talked about pods per node you say every
node is going to take 8 is going to have
eight parts per node so that slash 28
and there are 16 / 28 so you are good
from all the different scaling
perspective right you have slash 28
which gives you 16 IPS 32 IPS for
services and 16 / 28 so you are good to
go here so switching tracks from
container
native networking and from IP management
let's look at network security the
summary of the ask is that I come a
customer wants a completely isolated
cluster right they want to access Google
services privately they might have few
workloads which needs to access
third-party api's and for that they need
a deterministic IP and they want a
deterministic IP because the third the
third party vendor has a whitelist
blacklist policy which requires a
deterministic IP right so how do you
meet this forum how do you meet this
requirement you run something called GK
private clusters and in GK you private
clusters you we take away any public IP
and it's basically isolated from the
Internet now I want to clarify that when
I say it's isolated from the Internet
you can still configure an ingress or a
service type load balancer and allow
ingress incoming traffic to the cluster
from the Internet
okay so based on the slide there are
three steps to take to isolate your
cluster first is choosing the cluster
type we have primarily a public or a
private cluster if you you know
depending upon your requirement you can
choose between the two you can explore
the cluster on master and cluster master
is basically where we host the khc api
server the hce and you know scheduler as
well so that's that is in your control
as to how you're going to expose that
and then whitelisting access to that
cluster master so network security is a
shared responsibility in that it's our
responsibility to you know secure the
sick the the manage element but it's
your responsibility or the users
responsibility ensure that they are
using the right option to kind of logged
on the cluster master as well as the
worker nodes now in a private cluster as
I was talking about
there's only RFC 1918 addresses there's
no public IP right and this by default
prevents it from talking to the Internet
you in private clusters we turn on
private Google access by default which
means you can access any of the start or
Google API is privately but if you won't
have a requirement for certain workloads
to go out you can also integrate it with
flower
not so you can provision a cloud NAT and
integrate GK cursor with the cloud net
functionality second step is exposing
the cluster master endpoint so here you
have two options you can create a
private endpoint which gives a private
IP to the cluster master and this can be
used to access you know from on-prem if
you have a cube CTL client over there
you can use that private endpoint to
access from on Prem you can also expose
a public endpoint and this is especially
useful for road water use cases where
you have a remote worker who wants to
you know access your cluster master
however you expose a public endpoint
it's also accessible to any untrusted
actor as well so what we do is we give
you white listing black listing you know
a white listing facility through
authorized Network with which you can
decide you know you can allow the
trusted and this allow the untrusted so
to summarize before I want to talk more
about the authorized network but before
that let me summarize what we discussed
thus far so there is public endpoint and
private endpoint for accessing the
cluster master and in public clusters
you get only a public endpoint in
private clusters you can have you know
by default it gives you a private
endpoint and it also can extend a public
endpoint you for road water use cases
whitelisting through the authorized
network that I was talking about there
is a default behavior and there is an
eight different if there's another
behavior when you enable it I'm not
going to go through go through the table
but there is a lot of flexibility in
terms of different permutations and
combinations that we support to meet
your security and compliance
requirements DNA scaling so qpn s is a
service you know that is used for
interact lester within the cluster name
resolution right cube dns deployment
logic takes into account the size of the
cluster but it doesn't take into account
the number of you know request dns
request that might be going going across
right so the cube dns lookup takes up
contract entries so if you have a small
class so you might have an exam I tire
use case where it's a small enough
cluster but a very chatty application
which is in exhausting your contract
table which can be two issues
so you've what you can do is use DNS
order scaler to say
the daa2 to modify the number of DNS
backends that will run and this by
default the equation takes into account
the number of nodes and number of total
course across your cluster so what you
can do is you can override that if you
say that hey this is a small cluster I
am not satisfied with the number of
default backends I'm getting you can
increase an min number of backends or
you know DNS replicas that you want to
run as an example let's say you know
these you know you have 10 nodes 8 cores
per node so total 80 cores running in
the cluster so by default you are
getting because of the functions with
the logic you are getting to DNS
replicas but because the main setting
that you had you bumped it up to 5 right
so that's that's another way you can you
can you know get over the contract
issues and as you may know there are as
you may know there are some applications
that are heavy users of DNS you know
node.js is an example if you have
control over the name that they result
to you can avoid search path extensions
one of them is through the application
itself that is pointed out in the top
and the other one is through making
changes to the to the pod spec so with
that I'll hand it over to Bui so let's
now talk about running services at scale
so at first you may start off using an
in cluster based ingress controller
which just uses an ordinary proxy server
and uses service type load balancers to
expose it to the Internet you know this
is really familiar for a lot of us it's
just the standard proxy that you would
run on your laptop and then you would
expose your application to the Internet
using service type load balancer however
when your application scales up you will
really want to use the Google ingress
implementation in kubernetes engine this
is a container native ingress that's
globally scalable low latency
distributed proxy layer and has lots of
built-in features like caching
authentication DDoS protection you won't
have to fiddle with figuring out how
many instances of your proxy to scale to
or how to worry about absorbing an
attack but in addition to this what are
some best practices around using
services so first let's talk about
seamless services production services
often require software updates and
upgrades and ideally without disrupting
to your users kubernetes engine gives
you a bunch of knobs
to ensure your services are updated
without impact but how these pieces
interact can be subtle let's walk
through each of these pieces to
understand how they fit together to
ensure that your users won't see network
hiccups as you scale and update your
applications ok let's talk about a pause
lifecycle particularly focusing how the
pod lifecycle relates to services so
there are three basic states that govern
how your pod interacts with your
services first there is liveness this
determines whether or not your pod is up
for instance if your pod fails its
liveness check it will be restarted the
second bit is readiness this determines
whether or not your pod is fully booted
up and healthy and ready to serve
traffic for instance this is used by
workload managers such as a deployment
resource to see if it's ok to continue
updating your application finally there
are health checks these come from the
load balancer infrastructure itself in
our end-to-end checks of both Network
and application health ok
so let's walk through what a pod
lifecycle looks like and how to ensure
no service disruption so this diagram
depicts a time line of the pod status we
have a line for each of the three states
liveness readiness and health check
first we start the pod it should be
alive if it wasn't alive it would be
dead so then that would be under the
story ok so next comes health check and
readiness now these can go green
independent of each other but when they
go green your pod will start seeing
traffic the load balancer will be
sending traffic to your pod now your pod
is running for a while and you do an
update of your deployment here is when
your pod is going to be terminated what
the system will do is send your pod a
sig term if you don't handle it your pod
simply ends here however as you can see
it's still serving some traffic so you
will drop some requests on the ground if
you do handle it then what you should do
is start failing the health check and
readiness what this will do is tell the
load balancer to start draining the
traffic off of the pod finally after a
next amount of time kubernetes will
finally send the sit kill which will
kill your application for good so how do
we have seamless services let's recap so
the most important thing is when
kubernetes sends you a cig term you have
to start draining your application
request may still be in flight to your
application but no new ones will arrive
there now the way to tell the load
balancer that this is happening is to
fail the health checks and the readiness
probe second thing is after termination
grace period seconds your pod will be
killed
what's it kill now if you don't set the
setting its default is 30 seconds but if
your application takes longer than 30
seconds to service the last few requests
make sure you adjust the setting finally
sending these grace periods may impact
how fast a deployment can update so make
sure you tune your deployment max
surgeon max unavailable parameters to
take into account for this for instance
if you can only tolerate having one pod
being upgraded at a time then your
upgrade of your whole deployment will
proceed only one part at a time and will
have to wait for the grace period now
that we talked about
oh yes and one more thing if you have
infrastructure that needs to be
integrated into your pod life cycle that
does not necessarily come from your pod
itself for example you have to as part
of pod startup talk to a network load
balancer program the load balancer and
then inform the pod about the load
balancers condition there's a feature
called pod readiness gates which lets
you add these custom conditions from
outside of kubernetes back into your pod
lifecycle so how does this work well
here's your pod lifecycle and we see
that the readiness Gates actually slot
in in the readiness condition at the
front so one concern that you have when
you scale your backends to thousands is
that of load balance in the ideal case
you want your request traffic to be
evenly distributed across your backends
so here's a situation that actually has
come up a few times that we've seen is
suppose I have a load balancer with a
bad
or to backends in this case and traffic
is flowing and I have traffic to my
backends and now I want to scale up my
application now I have four backends and
we see that when we send traffic to
these backends it's actually
preferentially going to the older
backends so why is this and is random
shuffle not actually random so we know
that kubernetes and the load balancer
uniformly randomly sends requests across
all the backends so what's going on to
answer this question let's zoom in and
see what's happening let's take a deeper
look to see what the infrastructure
looks like so at the top we have Google
cloud load balancer and queue proxy now
requests are balanced to the nodes in
fact they're balanced evenly but the
queue proxy then balances connections to
the pods so if you see here we've scaled
up we added a few more connections but
when the requests come in traffic is
actually evenly balanced the VMS but and
this is especially true for newer
protocols like HTTP 2 there is
significant connection reuse and request
will actually likely go to older
backends causing an imbalance of
requests so how do we fix this so really
there's a disconnect between connections
and requests so what to do well there's
two options one of them is complex so
you can modify the back-end to return
headers indicating that connections
should not be really used basically the
crust of it is don't use the connections
too long and if you do this sufficiently
often you will eventually get a uniform
distribution of connections however
there's an easier answer which is to use
container native load balancing so with
Network endpoint groups in Google cloud
load balancer the load balancer seized
every pod back-end as an independent
entity in this case even you have a very
skewed set of connections from the load
balancer to the backend the low bouncer
can look at that look at the request and
send it to the least utilized back-end
and finally one final thing is this
problem really can crop up anytime you
use an elf for service type with can
actions and you have this kind of
aggressive connection reuse so this is
one thing to watch for okay so in
addition and this is container of native
load balancing you'll have a nice even
distribution of requests now in addition
to accurate load balancing when your lb
knows about your backends directly you
will have accurate health checks you
won't have the double hop through crude
proxy and you'll have much much better
visibility in debugging for example when
you go dump your traffic you'll see the
traffic go directly from the load
balancer to your back-end nothing in
between
no tracing needed through queue proxy or
IP tables now finally in terms of
scalable we should talk about failures
so the common way to think about
failures is to think about failure
domains and in this case we have to
think both about our data and control
plane what this means is that if you
have a single or maybe multiple faults
they won't cause disruptions to your
users now we could have failures of for
example of VM and if you have a
correlated failure where all of your
pause of your application are scheduled
on the same VM then you may have an
outage one way to avoid this is to use
scheduling constraints such as pada fin
anti affinity to distribute your pods
across the nodes in your cluster another
failure domain you want to consider is a
zone old failure for example in this
case uswest one a has gone down to
handle zonal failures you'd probably
should do two things one for your data
plane you should have node pools that
are spread across multiple zones and for
your control plane you will want to use
regional clusters regional clusters
gives you a distributed control plane
across multiple zones for your API
servers finally we forgot about one
thing which is the config plane so not
only do you have the data plane and the
control plane but you should be careful
that you can't make that one edit to a
I know we all did it and it takes down
your global network so ideally you
should have separation here as well
separate your clusters by namespaces or
by clusters for staging and production
make sure you stage a copy of kubernetes
resources test and commit the real thing
so that's the advantage of kubernetes is
this declarative model that can be
checked in and you can run CI CD on your
yeah moles in addition to thinking about
it at the sort of cluster or namespace
level you can also think about it at the
services level for example if you have a
service you can use those kubernetes
selectors to merge multiple deployments
together so you don't have that one
golden deployment that you can edit and
put all your eggs in that basket
okay so we've seen a couple of best
practices and now let's go over what
they actually look like on kubernetes
engine so first we're creating a cluster
and as we recall we want multiple
failure domains so we create a regional
cluster next we know that we want I P
flexibility and all the access of all
the features so we make sure it's a V PC
native cluster and also we have sort of
know about how our workload scales with
respect to IPS so we can set a smaller
maximum pods per node to kind of save on
IP address usage finally we use HTTP
load balancing which is the Google
ingress and we want a private cluster
because we want it to be secure and
finally we put apples using master
authorized networks so let's see what
this looks like when we make the cluster
can we switch okay so here so we have
this cluster right and we see that it
has three nodes in fact all of these
three nodes run across the distributed
control plane which is in a region
uswest one and in fact when we look at
our nodes we see that they use less
space than the default right because we
have scaled our cluster to be smaller
ip's per node so we can fit more know
into our network and also from a failure
domain perspective we see that it's
actually shorted across all of us one so
if one of these zonal chars goes down we
still are up now let's look at the
container native load balancer so this
is a standard definition for an
application with a load balancer we have
the deployment which I was speaking
about earlier with how you get your work
load in the cluster then we have a
service and the service is where we say
we want to use Network endpoint groups
which is the container native load
balancing and finally we expose the
application using ingress here now let's
take a look at what this load balancer
looks like so here we have the load
balancer that was created from that
snippet of configuration and you'll see
that it's split over three zones right
we have three zones for reliability and
in fact when we click into the zone
we'll see that all of my backends are my
pods so I have very accurate health
checks from the infrastructure telling
me whether that infrastructure the load
balancer to that particular pod directly
is healthy or not
all right so in summary what were some
of the best practices for using gke in
regards to networking well first you
should sit down and understand your
cluster IP space and plan for future
growth and also use VPC native clusters
to get the maximum flexibility in terms
of IP space planning the second thing is
make sure you understand what your
security requirements are but really you
should be using private cluster and
master authorized networks to secure
your clusters also tune your pod
lifecycle to avoid service disruption so
you know handle sig term make sure you
respond correctly to the readiness and
health checks use container native load
balancing for the best
performance and visibility of your
traffic and finally understand and plan
for failures on the three planes data
control and config and your feedback is
greatly appreciated so please fill out
the survey app at the end and you can
also submit your questions through booty
[Music]